- [Narrator] Biryani is a
perfectly cooked rice dish,
seasoned with whole spices and
layered between tender chunks
of meat and streams of delicious gravy.
It's a dish that will give you
the perfect bite each time.
Today we're gonna make our
favorite biryani recipe
that is sure to keep everyone
you know coming back for more.
(gentle music)
The origin of biryani is debatable.
Some say it originated in Iran,
making its way across
India through trade routes.
Others say it originated in Tamil Nadu.
One thing everyone can agree on however
is that biryani is delicious.
Almost every region of South Asia
has their own style of biryani.
Hyderabad's version is
extra saucy and flavorful.
In Tamil, ambur biryani is made
with mint, yogurt marinade.
And in Lucknow,
they sometimes use stock
to create a richer flavor.
Today we're going to be
making Bombay style biryani.
It's a little sweet and topped
with crispy fried onions.
Let's start with the meat.
There are many protein options
when it comes to making biryani,
like goat, lamb, shrimp and chicken.
For our recipe, we're going with chicken,
since it's the most traditional.
We're using bone in chicken
thighs and drumsticks.
Boneless chicken works too,
but bone-in will help to give
us a more flavorful dish.
To incorporate even more
flavor in our chicken,
we're going to marinate it.
We tested both a spice based marinade
and a yogurt based marinade.
We found that marinating with yogurt
is key to getting creamy, tender chicken.
So that's what we're going with.
Full fat yogurt works best.
In a large bowl, combine the yogurt,
ginger paste, garlic paste,
salt, cumin, coriander, garam masala,
chili powder and lime juice.
We'll add the chicken
and toss to coat well.
Then cover the bowl with
plastic wrap and marinate
for one hour at room temperature
or up to three hours in the refrigerator.
Now let's prepare our rice.
For this recipe, we will be using basmati.
It's fragrant, slightly nutty,
and will pair really nicely
with our mix of spices.
We'll start by gently rinsing
the rice in cool water.
Repeat this a few times
until the water runs clear.
Now we'll cover the rice with fresh water
and let it soak for 30 to 45 minutes.
Not only does soaking the rice
help to remove excess starch
and speed up the cooking process,
but for fragrant rice
like basmati and jasmine,
this will also help strengthen
their natural aroma and flavors.
Once the rice has finished soaking,
we'll move on to the cooking process.
To a pot of water, add cardamom pods,
a cinnamon stick, bay
leaf, cloves and salt.
When that comes to a
boil, we'll add our rice.
The key to perfectly cooked
biryani is to cook the rice
until it's only about three
quarters of the way done,
so it's still al dente.
This should only take about four minutes.
Drain.
Then add the rice to a
plate or baking sheet
and spread in an even
layer to cool like this.
Now that our rice is done,
we can move on to our
next three ingredients
that will make our biryani extra special.
Onions, prunes and potatoes.
We'll first boil the potatoes separately
until almost tender.
If we cooked them with the meat instead,
we'd end up with a mushy
texture in the final dish.
No thanks.
Once our potatoes are softened,
we're going to fry them in a neutral oil
to provide texture to our dish.
And the crunch doesn't stop there.
Next, we're gonna fry some onions.
A must when it comes to
Bombay style biryani.
We recommend using a small
red onion or shallot.
We'll fry them until they're
nice and golden brown.
Seriously, look how good those look.
Before we move on to layering our biryani,
we're going to make some saffron water.
Saffron adds a luxurious scent,
flavor and color to our biryani.
We know it can be pricey,
so if you don't have saffron on hand,
use turmeric to get that orange hue.
We're going to pour hot water
over our saffron threads.
And then gently crush them
with the back of a spoon
to get all of that flavor out.
Now let's make our gravy.
We tested a few different
oils for our gravy
and found that a mixture of oil
and ghee or clarified butter
creates the best flavor
without being too rich.
We'll heat our oil
mixture until it shimmers.
Then we're going to add
all of our whole spices
to get every last drop
of flavor out of them.
We want to fry them until
they are fragrant, not burnt,
about one to two minutes.
Then we'll add our
chopped onions and saute.
Once the onions begin to brown,
add the tomatoes and cook
for three to five minutes.
Then add the marinated chicken,
a splash of water and salt.
Cover and let this cook for 10 minutes.
We'll add the potatoes back in
and then add our special
ingredient, prunes.
Prunes are used in Bombay style biryani
to add an element of
sweetness to the dish.
Now that our gravy is finished,
let's move on to layering.
When it comes to cooking biryani,
there are a few ways to do it.
You can cook it dum-style.
which involves layering raw ingredients
in a heavy bottomed pot and
slow cooking them all together.
Or you can make it pukka-style,
which means cooking all of
the components separately
and then layering them together after.
We're cooking our biryani pukka-style,
because it's more traditional
for Bombay style biryani,
and it ensures we don't
overcook any of the elements
in the dish.
We'll start by reserving
half of the beautiful gravy
and add half of our rice into the pot.
Then we'll sprinkle some of
our saffron water on top.
We'll add some herbs, a little ghee,
and our fried onions as finishing touches
for the first layer.
And then we'll repeat the whole process
for the second layer.
Once we have our biryani all piled up,
we're going to cover the pot with foil
and seal it really tightly.
Traditionally, we'd
wrap the rim with dough
to get the tight seal we're looking for,
but today we're gonna keep
it simple by using foil.
Once it's done cooking, we'll
leave it covered to rest
for 10 minutes to let the
steam really fluff up the rice
and finish cooking.
And there you have it,
your beautifully layered Bombay biryani.
With biryani, every bit of time taken
to perfect this dish really pays off.
We're going to serve our biryani today
with a little onion
raita and pickled mango.
We know that nothing will
beat your moms biryani,
but we think this recipe comes very close.
(gentle music)